نحن الان داخل احد منافذ لبيع السلع
الغذائيه المعروفه باسم اهل الرمضان هذه
المنافذ التي تم افتتاحها بدايه شهر يناير
الماضي ومن المفترض ان تستمر حتى نهايه
رمضان تهدف لتوفير السلع باسعار مخفضه
تخفيفا عن كاهل للمواطنين الاقبال بدا
كبيرا داخل اروقه المنفذ مواطنون من كافه
الشرائح الاجتماعيه جاءوا للاستفاده من
العروض الاقبال كان مكثفا على اللحوم
والدواجن التي تشهد ارتفاعا كبيرا في
اسعارها اللحمه ب 240 بره هنا واخداها ب
160 وحلوه السعر عالي بره جدا هنا في في
تخفيضات حلوه في حاجات وحاجات لا اطلاقوا
هذه المبادرات يتزامن مع دعوات على صفحات
التواصل الاجتماعي لمقاطعه اللحوم
والدواجن بسبب الزياده الجنونيه في
اسعارها مواطنون استجابوا لهذه الدعوات
على امل ان تنجح في اجبار التجار على
تخفيض الاسعار انا مع المقاطعه مره بقت
على ضد الفراخ وضد اللحمه ده انت بتروح
تشتري كيلو اللحمه النهارده يقول لك ب 65
ثاني يوم تلاقيه ب 70 على طول اصحابه
محاليل جزاره اعترفوا بنجاح حملات
المقاطعه لكنهم برو ارتفاع اسعار اللحوم
باسباب خارجه عن ارادتهم على جزره اهو انا
مع المقاطعه بس مش لوحدي لازم ينزل قرار
بقفل الجزاره على الاقل مش اقل من 30 يوم
اللي عنده عجل واللي بيربي والناس اللي
مخبيه بهايمها في المزارع ومش هطلعها الا
في الغلا كل ده ياكل على حسابه كل بقى ما
فيش جزاره اكل بقى على حسابك غصبا عنه
هيبيعك الفتره الاخيره شهدت اغلاقا لبعض
محارب بيع الدواجن واللحوم اما بسبب نجاح
الحملات المقاطعه او لعدم قدره المواطنين
على الشراء في ظل زياده الاسعار احمد
عثمان العربيه القاهره